okay let's play mr orris wolf
this is never an easy game
okay i still have time to stop it right
okay let's go b5
and maybe knight c6
okay g5 we go b4 there is some geometry
so a3 we go h6
g6 like normally we go b3 but there is
no b3
so we will just have to start the game
in a very bad position
he plays bishop e4 and i know what the
point is
all right let's go d5 maybe in king d7
try to develop the pieces quickly
yeah this is how you end up playing
banter blitzes
it takes before okay so i will not even
consider uh
knight x before because it's not fun
enough so it's either e5 or
okay let's play e5 maybe or knight f6 i
was about to say
it's a funny thing is that the position
is probably still mean i wanted to say
about equal but it's
kind of
kind of weird to come up with uh this is
kind of fun
with this kind of evaluation and such
mess so what should i play here
i can play knight d4 or i can play
knight e7
i don't know okay let's play 94
now after e3 we have some q5 ideas
well this is actually about to happen
right i think you'll play three
or maybe c3 after c3 will probably have
to
slow down a little and uh go knight e6
[Music]
yeah go c3 okay let's go back
then at least we have a chance to to
finish the development after bishop d6
and some knight f6 k7
okay
d4 i think should be made by e4
95 check okay we have to take
so now both um e4 and d5 are under
attack i think we'll have to
sacrifice something here but it's not
it's not um such a bad news okay let's
go knight e7
sacrifice c4
yeah now we'll probably go king it
and um fade let's say
now i think i would be happy to play
rook to xf3
yeah that is unfortunate now i have to
sort of be responsible for what i'm
saying okay let's take
let's take and place it somehow
liking f7 or uh yeah maybe we can get
seven simply
queen c2 so he is trying to bring the
queen
to h7 there are four
i'll go g6
which allows bishop takes h6 but i don't
think it's uh
[Music]
that important will go knight f5
something like d4
maybe b should be seven in general we
have to do something obviously
um it looks kind of lost for black
but we have some
some attacking ideas for now and they
are about to
they are about to disappear so we have
to
we have to um act quickly okay let's
play rook g8
and uh you know we should be five
okay now i have to change the strategy
unfortunately
and try to vlog him
yeah i'm not good at this as you can see
oh i blundered this move okay
i think i managed okay sorry for that
i think i deserved to you know try to
[ __ ] someone
by being flocked for many many years
but yeah this was not ideal